queen of all vice's pride and there's a
very strange claim made on The View
yesterday this is by Sunny Hosten who
she's kind of the B team of the view
she's not Whoopi she's not Joy Behar but
she's one of the libs on the well
they're all Libs on you but she's she's
one of the more eccentric ones and and
she made a theological claim that
I'm no trained Theologian but it left me
scratching my head they were in a place
that accepts them for who they were and
someone came to that place
I don't know that they hide behind
religion because I said this on this
show once before Jesus would be the
Grand Marshal at the pride parade I
don't mean about gay people I mean in
every argument we have but here's your
weaponized religion but it's wrong if
you're so afraid why are you going over
there yeah if they scare you so much
leave them alone
Jesus would be the Grand Marshal of the
pride parade
what does that even mean
I get in a sense Christ is King of the
universe and so he's Grand Marshal of
all of creation and I guess there are
Pride parades in some places in creation
but what is that I don't think that's
what she's referring to what does that
mean Jesus would be the Grand Marshal of
the pride parade this is something that
the libs do all the time when it comes
to religion
and it's totally incoherent but what
they will say is
they'll say explicitly or implicitly at
least they'll say look I think
Christianity is dumb and stupid and
wrong and backward and dated and just
complete nonsense and all you people are
Lemmings and fools and idiots for
following the teachings of Christianity
hey
I don't believe in that I don't believe
in any of that stuff you know I mean I
don't believe in God I'm just you know
I'm just going to do me man and I'm just
so much smarter than everybody and I'm a
really Smart Genius atheist with a
fedora that I tip but also I'm much more
Christian you don't even understand
Christianity you know this is ridiculous
ridiculous line from people who I
promise you have not even a passing
familiarity with the religion it's it's
this phenomenon of oh this is the worst
one they'll say you'll hear from Libs
sometimes they'll say listen I went to
Catholic school for 10 years
and uh so I'm I'm basically I'm
basically Saint Augustine you know I'm
I'm basically Thomas Aquinas all right
because I briefly went to a Catholic
High School so and I'm a complete
apostate and Fallen away from the faith
but let me tell you about your religion
right that's what they that's what they
all do and what is the why do they do it
they do it because they reject religion
as
an intellectual matter but they
recognize at least subconsciously that
man is a religious being and so they
have to make religious arguments they
recognize the strength of religion even
in their own lives even in how it pulls
on them and so what they do is they
align their view they claim that their
views are the views of God
what Christians do
what religious people do is that they
you using their moral conscious and
their faculties of reason and their
respect for tradition and their reading
of the scripture and their participation
in the Liturgy they ascertain what God
wants yes they can
and then when their behavior doesn't
jive with what God wants they change
their behavior and attempt to change
their behavior and repent which means to
change your mind and to bring their
views and behaviors into line with what
God wants what the libs do is exactly
the opposite
when they realize that there's a huge
Gulf between what God wants as stated in
the scripture in the sacred tradition as
perceived by our moral conscience
and our reason
a gulf between that and their own
behavior
they tried to conquer
God's will they say my will is God's
will they try to make of themselves gods
they do what the serpent tells even the
Garden of Eden he it he they they say
that we shall be as gods and this is
what Whitaker chamber said is the very
heart of of Communism is is man making
themselves Gods it's the heart of
radical leftism
that is all they're going to do well if
you've got to live in a world in which
God is the Grand Marshal which Christ is
the Grand Marshal
or the world in which Sunny Hosten is
the Grand Marshal which are you going to
pick you got to pick one right now head
on over to goodranchers.com Knowles you
know I love spending the holidays with
my family and one of the ways I like to
do that is with delicious meat from good
ranchers as a special gift to our
listeners this holiday season good
ranchers is giving away two Black Angus
New York strip steaks free with your
order these are two 12 ounce Steakhouse
quality Cuts that's a 70 value for free
you don't want to miss this offer let me
tell you why Black Angus tastes better
and is more tender than any other beef
black angus meat is marbled in such a
way that the fat is distributed thinly
and evenly this marbling gives it a
consistent flavor that you don't get
with other meats plus the Black Angus
from good ranchers is hand cut and
trimmed by expert butchers so you know
every piece is going to be Exquisite
while grocery store meat prices are on
the rise good ranchers is dedicated to
helping you save as much as possible if
you subscribe to good ranchers today you
can lock in your price and avoid these
insanely high prices at the grocery
store and get some free meat while
you're at it go to goodrancers.com use
code Knolls at checkout for this special
offer that is goodranchors.com Knowles
for two Black Angus New York strip
steaks with your order for free good
ranchers American Meat delivered you're
seeing a major fight play out in the
Senate right now and very few people are
talking about it
the Liberals aren't talking about it
because they think they've got the fight
in the bag and the Republicans aren't
talking about it because they're
absolute cowards and moral idiots but we
need to focus on this this is a very
important fight it's over the
redefinition of marriage and the Not
only destruction of of the institution
of marriage but the obliteration of
religious liberty from American public
life and this is through something
called the respect for Marriage Act most
Preposterous euphemism we've ever had in
American law and what the respect for
Marriage Act does is it ensure not only
enshrines the legal definition of
marriage from obergefil which is
preposterous
but it actually goes much further than
that and it prevents lots and lots of
Americans from objecting in any
significant way to that radical
redefinition of marriage so if you
believe as do uh Christians and Jews and
Muslims and sensible people uh
throughout all of history until five
minutes ago if you believe as did Barack
Obama in 2011 well into his first term
that marriage is an institution between
a man and a woman the sexual difference
has something to do with marriage then
you're basically booted from public life
at this point if you express that in any
significant way if this law passes it's
a disaster and a dozen squish morally
vacuous Republicans and intellectual
evacuous Republicans voted for this
thing
so they voted to get past the filibuster
which means now it's on a fast track to
get a vote we can still hold this thing
up a little bit
we're not going to defeat the bill the
bill is going to pass but what Mike Lee
the great senator from Utah who came
pretty close to losing his re-election
bid and we had him on this show because
it was just awful to think that Mike Lee
was not going to win re-election well
Mike Lee coming to the rescue here with
the Lee amendment to give protections
for Christians and Jews and Muslims and
sensible agnostics and atheists too uh
to to be able to express the real
meaning of marriage without facing
punishment from the federal government
in the Public Square why does this
matter a lot of conservatives write in
they say you know Michael I'm with you
on a lot of things but I just don't care
about this marriage stuff if the gays
want to get married and be as miserable
as the rest of us you know who cares
that's fine by me and haha yes I know we
all tell that joke it's a little bit
glib but I get it it's a kind of funny
Barb however it obviously matters
it obviously matters because marriage is
the fundamental political institution
it's the building block of all of
Politics the libs think and want for the
building block of politics to just be
the individual because it's much easier
to dominate individuals when they're
atomized and broken up from
intermediating institutions most notably
the family the conservatives understand
that the family is key and the family is
not just some socially constructed
institution where we can say okay we're
going to make a polycule with three
girls and two guys and a goat and that's
going to be the new definition of a
family no marriage is not socially
constructed it is a there are social
aspects to it and and
intellectualized and ritualized aspects
to it but it is a natural institution as
Aristotle observed as St Thomas Aquinas
observed as smart people throughout all
of human history have observed because
man is naturally a pairing being we are
drawn to our the complementarity of the
Sexes and by the complementarity of the
Sexes and within that unit of one man
and one woman
there is the possibility of life and
marriage is instituted for the good of
the spouses and the sake of the
generation and the education of children
okay that is what the thing is for and
and so if you find yourself in a
position where you say well who I just
don't care I just don't see what the big
deal is then maybe ask yourself
why don't you see what the big deal is
maybe just take a step back and say you
know with a little bit of humility here
this institution
has been viewed for all of human history
by all the smartest people and pretty
much everyone else too as extremely
important
and it still remains viewed as extremely
important by the liberal activists who
are trying to radically redefine him and
actually the only people ever in the
history of the world who don't think
this thing matters
is just like me and some of my Live and
Let Live kind of laissez-faire
libertarian friends why is that
maybe maybe
you're missing something here maybe a
lot of people are missing something here
as to why this thing has been viewed is
so important by pretty much everybody
ever so what the what the Lee Amendment
proposes
is based on an Infamous exchange from
the obergefell decision that redefined
marriage
and it was when Sam Alito conservative
judge asked whether religious
universities that were opposed to
same-sex marriage would lose their
tax-exempt status if marriage were
redefined at the federal level
and varilli speaking for the government
said it's certainly going to be an issue
I don't deny that I don't deny that
Justice Alito it is going to be an issue
so Mike Lee writes it is an issue a
burgerfeld did not make a private right
of action for aggrieved individuals to
sue those who oppose same-sex marriage
it did not create a mandate for the
Department of Justice to sue where it
perceived an institution opposed
same-sex marriage but the respect for
Marriage Act will this radical bill that
the libs are pushing through that the
squish Republicans are are going along
with what we can expect
should this bill become law is more
litigation against those institutions
and individuals trying to live according
to their sincerely held religious
beliefs and moral convictions and even
most absurdly the people who are going
to be on the back foot here and who are
going to have to constantly defend
themselves against lawsuits are going to
be the people with sincerely held
religious beliefs and moral convictions
that are correct
they're not just sincerely held they're
true and they're going to be the ones
who are going to be destroyed by this
we're all going to be Jack Phillips
we're all going to be masterpiece cake
shop it will obliterate any defense of
what is now
called traditional marriage it's also
known as marriage it's going to
obliterate what remains of that defense
from the Public Square I urge you call
your Congressman call your senators
tell them to vote against this bill
at least until the Lee amendment is
adopted it might be a largely lost cause
for the moment
to defeat the bill entirely which we
should do we can I think still get the
Lee Amendment through call your Senator
especially if your Senator is one of the
Dozen squishes who voted uh to over
override the filibuster and get this
thing on a fast track call your Center
and tell them to stop this nonsense the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss this okay if you are not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign